If you concentrate solely on your
career,
you can get along way in your career,
and I would say that that's a strategy
that a minority of men preferentially
do,
that that's all they do.
They worked like 70,
80 hours a week.
They'd go flat out on their career.
They're staking everything on the small
probability of exceptional status in a
narrow domain,
but it's.
It's hard on them.
They don't have a life.
It's very difficult for them to have a
family.
They don't know how to take any leisure
activity like they get very one
dimension.
Now it may be that that unit
dimensionality is the price you have to
pay to be exceptional at one thing,
right?
Because if you're going to be something
like a genius level mathematician and
you want to do that for,
or a scientists say,
it's like you're in your lab,
you're in your lab all the time.
You're working 70 hours a week or 80
hours a week,
you're smart,
you're dedicated,
you're unit dimensional,
and that's how you get to beat all the
other people who are doing that.
It's the only way,
but the problem is you don't get a life.
Now,
if you love being a scientist and you
have that kind of focus of mind,
well first of all,
you're a rare person and second you're
going to pay for it,
but fine.
More power to you,
but,
but it's,
uh,
it's a risky business to do that.
You sacrifice a lot for it.
You know,
and I would say most often if you're
speaking about having a healthy life,
that isn't what you do.
You spread yourself out more.
So you know,
you have a family,
you have some things that you do outside
of work that are meaningful to you and
useful.
You,
you have a network of friends,
um,
that,
those three things,
a loaner for things,
a loner,
plenty to keep you well oriented.
And then if one of those things
collapses,
you know,
everything doesn't go now.
The price you pay for that is,
the more you strive to optimize that
balance,
the less likely you are to be
fantastically successful at any single
one of them.
But you might have a very,
you know,
if you consider your life as a whole,
that might be a winning strategy.
One of the things,
Carl Young,
sad,
I really liked this.
He thought that men went after
perfection and when women went after
wholeness,
so there are different,
there are different value there.
They're different.
There's something different at the top
of the value hierarchy.
So perfection would be steak,
it all in one thing and look for radical
success.
Not all,
not that all men do that because they
don't.
But we're talking about extremes at
least with regards to the men that do
that.
The wholeness ideas more like,
well,
I want,
I want.
It's like I want one thing in my life to
be 150 percent or I want five things in
my life to be 80 percent.
Well there,
there's a lot more richness in a life
where you have five things operating at
80 percent,
but you're not operating in any at any
of them at 150 percent.
So,
and I really believe this because I've
watched men and women go through their
careers now for a long period time and
one of the things that there's lots of
things that produce this,
but one of the things that I've noticed
is that mostly women in their thirties
bear bail out of unidimensional
dimensional careers.
They won't do them.
They won't.
They won't put it in the 80 hours a week
that they would have to put in in order
to dominate that particular area.
And it isn't.
The reason that they won't do it is
because they decide it's not worth it
and no wonder because why would that be
worth it?
You have to ask yourself that.
It's like,
well,
you want to be an outstanding
scientists.
Like,
okay,
really,
that's what you want because that means
that's what you do because you're
competing with other people.
You know,
they're smart,
they're hardworking,
and if you want to be at the top,
you have to be smarter and work harder
than any of them.
And working hard means working long
hours.
I mean,
it also means working diligently,
but in in the final analysis,
it's also an additive issue.
If I'm smart and hard working and I can
crank out for 70 hours a week and you do
it for 30,
it's like in two years,
I'm so far ahead of you.
You will never ever catch up.
So anyways.
And I think partly maybe part of the
reason too that women are oriented that
way more than men.
I think there's two reasons is one is
socioeconomic status does not make women
more attractive on the mating market,
but it does make men more attractive.
And the second is women's timeframe is
compressed,
right?
Because guys can always say,
well I'll have kids later and they can
say that until they're like 80.
Whereas women,
it's like,
no way man.
You gotta get you gotta get it together.
By the time you're,
let's say 40,
but really probably by 35,
but definitely by 40 because otherwise
it ain't happening and that's bloody
dreadful.
Like the most unhappy people you ever
see.
No,
no.
One of the common roots to extreme
unhappiness is to want children and not
have the.
I wouldn't recommend that.
You know,
you see couples who were in their
thirties,
one couple in three over the age of 30
has fertility problems that's defined as
an inability to conceive after one year
of trying one in three.
So it's worth thinking about because
people are very,
very unhappy.
If they want to have kids and then they
can't,
man,
you're in the medical mill for 10 years.
If that's,
if that's what happens to you.